it announced top five burger okay yeah
absolutely
it's sure SH not Shake Shack though No
awesome that you chose and I'm here to
rub the one and only shake shot the one
burger that matters oh my god going on
in and out raised on in and out straight
up eat in and out every day there's just
nothing special about the Shake Shack
burger Oh God
taking everything very personally first
of all this fund is burned dense bun is
crispy golden this bun tours in front of
this soft potato bun why are these buns
made out of right oh my god it's a
little salty you can barely see the
burger in here and then look at this
it's overflowing the circumference of
the Shake Shack burger is smaller than
the anapa I promise you there's twice
the amount of meat in this even smaller
burger than this one well I hope there's
double the meat because it's double the
price of an amount burger so you can get
a double cheeseburger for less than one
regular burger I would call this a
public sauce as opposed to a delicious
secret sauce it's wet it's like drooling
on me I don't like my burgers drool on
me I like them to be a little bit more
composed mmm fresh Lou's new dirty
oh cool here's my one frog yeah you want
to be you know props to in and out
they throw a potato right in a machine
they crank it there and two seconds
later it's in a bath of hot oil well I
think that makes them a little bland
this is delicious sauce secrets this is
congealed baby vomit I do like the Shake
Shack fryer and I fry suck so bad that's
why they have to cover with all this
animal style nonsense they're not
flavorful or crunchy oh I'm gonna dip it
in no no not a contaminant like oh that
is so rude I need to mash it up and pour
some gravy on it that's the only way
that this is edible right around I have
to give it to Shake Shack this one's
more fast-food II this one's more like
wow is it come from an expensive
overpriced ice cream store then they
have Bible verses no these are pagan
shakes also it's a boring cup oh look at
this I'm getting any nee nee nee nee nee
nee nee nee cool we get a California for
the past 16 years if I had only one arm
to carry a milkshake with down the
street remember if I pick up the shake
but this kind of breaks me but I have to
say Shake Shack have you ever had a
Neapolitan one from in-n-out no hmm is
that one of the secret things so that's
why I love about our restaurant hey lar
good food secret well have fun
I think it's cool makes me feel like a
spy
Nutan Jesus would have gifted his
disciples with in and out yes
and then Judas probably got shake shop
that's not true